Speaker 1: Bill o'reilly failed. Fox News host
bill o'reilly has come out of the woodwork with
advice for herschel walker and I promise this
is it for Herschel Walker stuff for the week
unless something insane happens. If this is
really it for Herschel Walker stuff. This
is more about Bill O'Reilly. Bill O'Reilly put
together some advice for Herschel Walker that
I have to tell you in some way makes sense,
which is a weird thing to say about anything
Bill O'Reilly had to say. Take a look.
Speaker 2: Ah, he's been on his program.
I know him a little bit. But every two weeks
there's another scandal about Herschel Walker.
And the latest one is that he had a
girlfriend and he paid for an abortion.
For the girlfriend. Now, the news
agency to put that out is a far left.
Revolting news agency, Daily Beast.
Speaker 1: The Daily Beast actually
does some pretty good reporting. But okay.
Speaker 2: You know, it's like, okay. And
Walker went on HANNITY last night and said this.
Go. I never asked anyone to get an abortion. I
never paid for an abortion. And it's a lie. And
I'm going to continue to fight it. That's what
they want. They want to see. Okay. Here's
what you got to do, Herschel. And I'm just
talking to you like a human being. Please.
This is a serious accusation. If you did it.
You got to say who did it. I
don't know how you do that, but
you can't lie about it.
Speaker 1: Especially
at this point. How do you do it.
Speaker 2: If you did not do it?
Then you've got to go after The Daily Beast.
You got to have your attorneys sue them.
And if there is a person alleging that she
had an abortion, you got to see that person.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Now, remember that Herschel
Walker three days ago said tomorrow morning
we're filing a defamation suit. As of this
moment, no such suit has been filed. And
that's a really common thing that happens
in the sort of celebrity in politics space,
which is you say you're going to file a defamation
suit. But of course, if it's true, it's not
defamation. And as Michael Cohen mentioned, when
I appeared on his program, we recorded an episode.
If filing that lawsuit opens up discovery and you
might end up getting deposed. And so you really
don't do it unless it's actually defamation.
Speaker 2: If you did not do it. And you have to
do that now. So that the people in Georgia will
go on. What the deuce is this, right? Every two
weeks we got another child fathered by Mr. Walker
or this or whatever. But if this is not true.
Then your lawyers have to mobilize now.
Speaker 1: Yeah. And why aren't they?
Speaker 2: And you have to hold a
press conference with your lawyers,
and you have to say this is false.
Speaker 1: Imagine Herschel Walker
trying to read a statement at a press
conference and going completely off the rails.
Speaker 2: Never happened. And we're going to file
this against The Daily Beast. Now, if you do that
and indeed, if you did not pay for an abortion,
then that will turn that race around. Hmm.
You'll win your seat. Maybe because Georgians
will see you rightly as a victim of this smear.
But if you did it. You lose, right?
Even if you admit you did. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So, I mean, Bill O'Reilly's kind
of right here. Only insofar as Walker doesn't
actually have to admit that it's true. But if he
doesn't and he keeps denying it in increasingly
less credible ways, and we learn more and more
about the alleged truth, and that includes that
not only is this woman someone who had an
abortion after being impregnated by Walker,
but is also the mother of one of his kids,
it's going to become a very difficult story to
credibly deny. So I have to say to some degree,
Bill O'Reilly giving some sensible advice.